hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute habe ich meine Mama zu Gast und
meine Mama macht das weltbeste Tor
[Musik]
ist eingelegtes Gemüse und ich muss
sagen ich bin
35 wow ich habe es gedroppt
und ich habe noch nie Zuschuss selber
gemacht ich habe noch nie Gemüse so ist
meine Mama macht selber eingelegt das
machen wir jetzt heute zusammen ein paar
Gemüsesorten sind aus dem Garten ein
paar andere aus dem Markt und das
wichtigste ist beim Einlegen von Gemüse
ihr braucht sterile Gläser es gibt auch
extra fermentiert Gläser es gibt auch
diese großen Schraubgläser und die
Salzlake also dieses Essig Wasser mit
Salz das ist das Besondere und das macht
meine Mama einfach am besten und das ist
Mama tot ich weiß jeder legt sein Gemüse
irgendwie anders ein aber wir machen
jetzt Methode von meiner Mama und ich
habe jetzt hier einen großen Topf und
ähm Mama hat ja auch gesagt wir lassen
das jetzt einmal kochen damit auf jeden
Fall nicht kippt gell damit alles steril
ist alles super ist und natürlich habe
ich hier den alle mit Topf denn das ist
meine Mama ich schreibe ich dann das
genaue Rezept einfach in die App bzw in
den Block denn meine Mama macht das
immer nach Augenmaß sie schmeckt halt
immer ab das heißt ich mess dann alles
für euch ganz genau ab jedenfalls
braucht ihr dafür Wasser ihr braucht
Essig ich habe jetzt hier ein Apfelessig
Salz ordentlich Salz und ganz bisschen
Zucker wir schmeißen noch Pfefferkörner
und Senfkörner schmeiße ich jetzt mit
rein macht meine Mama eigentlich ne aber
wir haben gedacht so gerade bei den
Gurken oder so könnte es dazu passen
also kommt das jetzt in der Topf ja das
Wasser hier rein
dann kommt Essig dazu dann direkt Salz
dazu endlich meine Salzmenge mit der ich
mich identifizieren kann sogar
kommen
perfekt und Senfkörner können wir gleich
in die Gläser machen gut dann lassen wir
das jetzt kurz kochen und ich habe schon
die Gläser sterilisiert einfach hier im
Dampfbackofen ich habe nämlich einen
Backofen mit Dampffunktion da kann ich
oben einfach den Wasserbehälter
reinsetzen dann das ganze auf Dampf
schalten und die Gläser 20 Minuten
sterilisieren ihr könnt sie aber auch
ganz einfach auf dem Herd abkochen oder
auch gerne bei ganz heißem Programm in
die Spülmaschine schmeißen und dann eben
ganz heiß verwenden was machen wir jetzt
so lange wir bereiten das Gemüse vor ja
denn wir haben hier Karotten wir haben
grüne Tomaten aus dem Garten wir haben
kleine Gurken zum Einlegen Rotkohl
Sellerie
grüne Peperoni wir haben hier noch
Weißkohl und da hat Mama gesagt am
besten Spitzkohl nehmen oder den
türkischen Weißkohl wie heißt denn der
auf deutsch
doch an Weißkohl
und wir haben hier Knoblauch und zwar
einige Knoblauchzehen die sind hier
sogar aus der Türkei denn wir sind in
Side immer ganz gerne im Restaurant im
Boutique Hotel und Restaurants und der
macht das weltbeste Knoblauchbrot das
mache ich euch mal und er hat mir ganz
viel Knoblauch mitgegeben weil das dann
richtig leckerer knoblauch ist aber ihr
könnt natürlich ganz normale
Knoblauchzehen verwenden dann mach du
Gemüse und also mach du das hier und ich
mache das an der Maschine oder zeig Herz
Daniela
also die flache Weißkohl Variante auch
gerne als türkenkohl bezeichnet
unterscheidet sich nicht nur in der Form
sondern auch durch die weichere lockere
Struktur und einem ausgezeichneten
Geschmack vom runden Weißkohl und wird
daher auch gerne als Delikatess oder
Aroma Kohl bezeichnet flach Kohl
türkenkohl heißt der wie lustig nennt
sich aber auch Roma Kohl
cool und du hast gesagt der wird weicher
gell siehst du Mamas Visa alles
ich bin auch eine Mama und ich wusste es
nicht
[Musik]
den Weißkohl und Rotkohl könnt ihr
wieder grob in Stücke schneiden mag ich
auch gerne oder in feine Streifen
[Musik]
das war es eigentlich schon Gläser sind
da Mischung ist vorbereitet Gemüse ist
da jetzt wird alles reingeschichtet
wichtig ist dass das ganze Gemüse mit
Flüssigkeit bedeckt ist und bei den
fermentiergläsern habe ich sogar was um
das Glas zu beschweren
okay
[Musik]
so nicht so voll machen
fällt ja sowieso noch ein bisschen
zusammen das Gemüse auch wenn sich das
gleich setzt
okay dann Flüssigkeit rein ja und
[Musik]
Knoblauch
dass man den noch schneiden wenn du
willst kannst du Sellerieblätter
gerne ein bisschen drücken
und aufgießen
[Musik]
gut hier bei den Gläsern gibt sogar noch
was zum Beschweren so ein Glas
ansonsten gibt es auch im türkischen
Supermarkt auch Einmachgläser und da ich
immer wie so ein Gitter und presst man
das Gitter so drauf
so gut und hier gebe ich jetzt den
Deckel drauf wie gesagt das sind extra
fermentiert Gläser die Regeln dann auch
von alleine den Gasaustritt das heißt
hier oben ist so ein Ventil drin das
kommt von alleine raus das braucht dann
so ungefähr vier Wochen dann ist das
Gemüse fertig eingelegt in normalen
Gläsern muss man auch aufpassen der
nicht so voll und muss man da ab und zu
das Gas rauslassen wie oft
einmal in der Woche einmal die Woche bis
es richtig
genau dann so einmal die Woche Gas
entweichen lassen wieder verschließen
ansonsten kannst du nicht passieren dass
es überläuft cool mein erstes
selbstgemachtes
[Musik]
machen
ein Glas Sommer für den ganzen Winter
für ein Jahr haben wir jetzt glaube ich
zur schifffahrrad also probiert das
Rezept gerne aus natürlich wollte ich
eigentlich das Video in vier Wochen
hochladen damit wir dann gemeinsam
probieren können aber ich dachte mir
kommt ich lade es jetzt hoch jetzt könnt
ihr auch euer Gemüse Einlegen in vier
Wochen probieren wir es einfach zusammen
ins Stories oder wie auch immer und dann
gucken wir einfach wie es sich verhält
wie gesagt die Gläser muss ich nicht
lüften die haben Ventil die muss ich
einmal die Woche mal Lüften reinschauen
in 4 Wochen ungefähr sollte es soweit
sein probiert's gerne aus Elena salak
Annette
danke schön
also probiert aus die genaue
Mengenangabe schreibe ich euch in den
Block vielleicht nicht die große Menge
weil das war jetzt schon fertig ich
glaube wir haben dreimal das Wasser noch
mal nachgekocht und ja abonniert gerne
den Kanal kommentiert gerne schreibt
auch gerne was euer lieblings Mama
Rezept ist und ich freue mich schon
drauf essen zu dürfen macht's gut bis
zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]